doctors in the South Pacific island
nation of Samoa are still seeing new
cases in a massive deadly measles
outbreak the virus has infected more
than 4,800 people at least 70 of them
have died including many young children
the Samoan government says ninety-one
percent of everyone eligible is now
vaccinated but that's not quite enough
93 to 95 percent of a population must be
immune to prevent measles from spreading
in the US where the government estimates
the vaccination rates of kindergarteners
at least 14 states are below this
immunity threshold that's concerning
Carter Evans traveled to Samoa to get a
first-hand look at the crisis there
this is Samoas main hospital and health
officials have set up tents in the
parking lot to help with a large number
of measles patients the government has
mounted an aggressive vaccine campaign
which it hopes will help but it's clear
now this outbreak will have a
life-changing impact on families
it's Allah and tomorrow Paula poi Louis
says the measles outbreak took hold of
this family in an instant the disease
killed three of his five children so
they got sick and four days later they
died their mother follow so is so
distraught she sleeps on her children's
grave which is set up in the family's
front yard according to Samoan tradition
she told me it's her only way to be
close to them now it's gonna take a long
time to heal community advocate Lena
Chang is helping the families of measles
victims when you see that what do you
think
heartbreaking heartbreaking it's
shouldn't shouldn't happen this way
experts say the measles is entirely
preventable but so far more than two
percent of the island nation's
population has been infected most of the
deaths are children including this
ten-year-old boy whose funeral was held
over the weekend
as the most complicated and thankful
seeing only 31% of Samoans were
vaccinated around the time of the
outbreak in part because of fears that
spread last year after two infants died
when nurses incorrectly mixed their
vaccines with another medicine the
vaccines are now mandatory here and the
government is cracking down on the
spread of misinformation authorities
recently arrested a quote alleged
anti-vaxxer after they said he publicly
disputed the vaccine drive saying I'll
be here to mop up your mess enjoy your
killing spree I think what we've learned
from this episode and this epidemic is
the absolute importance of getting the
right message out to the communities
educating the communities on the
importance of having the vaccine while
the Samoan vaccination rate has nearly
tripled in a matter of weeks there are
still challenges Samoan families often
have many children in close contact this
baby surrounded by family was just
released from the hospital the measles
vaccine is the one safe and cost
effective way of protecting children
from measles in this day and age we
shouldn't see the measles in in any
country and we're seeing a lot of cases
globally there's been double the number
of cases reported just in the last two
years Samoa is still under a state of
emergency and now the nearby u.s.
territory of American Samoa is also
declaring an emergency after nine people
there contracted the disease for CBS
this morning Carter Evans
Poppaea Samoa Carter thank you very much
you know before the vaccine was
available a million people a year used
to die of the measles we've kind of
forgotten that it's very hard way to
relearn that lesson to see these kids
suffer today and we take it for granted
here in this country you get the vaccine
and you carry on